- Il aura été l'un des plus
puissants criminels du Québec.
Maurice Boucher est né en 1953,
à Causapscal dans le bas
Saint-Laurent, il grandit
dans le quartier Hochelaga
Maisonneuve à Montréal.
Une vie de petit truand,
grand consommateur de drogues,
condamné pour vol à main armée
à 22 ans.
Vers la fin des années 80,
il fonde son propre chapitre
des Hells Angels :
s s s Nomads, un des groupes
les plus craints.
Mais "Mom" a de l'ambition.
C'est l'époque de la guerre
des motards.
BENOIT PERRON  ex-enquêteur,
Escouade régionale mixte de MTL
- Le but de cette guerre-là,
c'était vraiment le contrôle
total au Québec et en Ontario,
une partie de l'Ontario;
le contrôle total sur le traffic
de stupéfiants.
(bombe)
- Des bombes sautent,
les motards s'entretuent
allègrement, faisant au passage
d'innocentes victimes comme
le jeune Daniel Desrochers,
11 ans. En 97, coup sur coup,
deux gardiens de prison sont
assassinés, l'un par Stéphane
Godasse Gagné, qui devient
délateur, et accuse Maurice
Boucher d'avoir commandé
les meurtres.
Le chef des Hells Angels
est alors arrêté, mais acquitté,
entouré de sa garde.
Il nargue les policiers
par son tempérament fron,,,
se présentant sans gêne
en public.
Mais la fin est proche...
- C'est sûr qu'il va y avoir
un appel.
- La proururur France
Charbonneau se bat pour que
Boucher subisse un second
procès. Le vent toune pour
les Hells. L'escouade carcajou
multiplie les assauts contre
s s s motards, l'opération
Printemps 2001 décapite
le chapitre Nomad.
Maurice Boucher subit un second
procès. Cette fois-ci, en 2002,
il est condamné à perpétuité.
Même à l'intérieur des murs,
il continue àiririr.
En 2015, il est condamné
pour avoir comploté le meurtre
du caïd Raynald Desjardins.
Son influence au sein du crime
organisé s'évanoui,
mais son rêve d'expansion
des Hells Angels persiste.
- On peut dire, aujourd'
sans se tromper, que la majorité
des territoires au Québec et
suite à la fin de la guerre des
motrard en Ontario, il y a eu la
création de chapitres aussi
des Hells en Ontario.
D'une certaine façon, oui,
il a réussi.
- ààà l'écart des autres
détenus à l'intérieur de
Saint-Anne-des-Plaines,
Maurice Mom Boucher a succombé
à un cancer de la gorge
dans l'ombre la plus totale.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Montréa